en los vídeos anteriores hemos visto que
estas dos moléculas que tenemos aquí son
diferentes verdad porque no se pueden
superponer sobre sus imágenes espejo
digamos de la una de la otra verdad así
que en realidad estos son una especie de
esteroides o - que vamos a llamar en
anti o menos verdad estos dos son en
anti o meros el uno del otro este de
aquí y este de acá aunque la dificultad
viene a la hora de darles un nombre
asignarles un nombre verdad porque los
dos podrían llamarse bromo cloro flúor o
metano así que como vamos a distinguir
entre estos dos enantiómero si lo que
necesitamos usar es el sistema rs ok así
que vamos a ir pasando los distintos
pasos verdad que para que podamos ver
cómo asignarle un nombre a cada uno de
estos en anti o menos ok entonces el
primer paso que el primer paso nos dice
que hay que asignar una prioridad a los
grupos unidos al centro de calidad por
el número atómico que entonces vamos a
irnos primero con con el de la izquierda
entonces digamos de este que tenemos a
la izquierda y rápidamente podemos ver
que el centro de quiralidad o el centro
final es el carbono verdad y ahí tenemos
los cuatro grupos unidos a este carbono
en este caso son cuatro átomos verdad y
podemos fijarnos en que son hidrógeno
bromo floro y cloro y podríamos pensar
cuál tiene el número atómico más alto ok
de hecho por eso aquí tengo una versión
corta de la de la tabla periódica de
verdad y podemos ver que el bromo el
bromo aquí tiene el mayor número atómico
así que el bromo tiene la prioridad
mayor verdad y obtiene nuestro número
uno ahora después podemos ver que sigue
el cloro este sería nuestro número 2
seguiría el flúor o el personal el flúor
porque tiene un número atómico de 9 y
finalmente el hidrógeno que tiene un
número atómico
la verdad y tenemos digamos nuestros
órdenes de prioridad según el número
atómico muy bien ahora vámonos con el
segundo paso nos dice que hay que
orientar los grupos de tal suerte que el
de menor prioridad proyecte hacia atrás
verdad o que se está proyectando hacia a
digamos a lo lejos de ti se está
alejando de ti verdad y eso es
justamente lo que tenemos en esta imagen
verdad el hidrógeno justamente ya se
está yendo digamos hacia atrás de la
hoja en donde estamos trabajando verdad
eso es lo que significa la línea
punteada y bueno ya hemos en ese sentido
completado el paso 2 y vamos a mostrar
en un vídeo en donde vamos a mostrar
esto todavía un poco más claro en dónde
realmente orientamos el grupo de más
baja prioridad hacia digamos alejándose
de nosotros si el amarillo es el cloro
el rojo es el bromo el verde es el flúor
y el blanco es el hidrógeno simplemente
tenemos que rotarlo un poco para que el
hidrógeno apunte completamente hacia
atrás así que si lo hemos rotado podemos
ver que el cloro está a la derecha el
bromo a la izquierda y el flúor hacia
abajo con esto hemos terminado digamos
el paso 2 y ahora que ya está hecho esto
nos movemos al paso 3 que es determinar
si la sucesión 1 2 3 va en la dirección
de las manecillas del reloj o en contra
de las manos
y el reloj verdad entonces según lo que
vimos en el videito podríamos poner esto
así verdad teníamos el cloro de este
lado el perdón el cloro a la derecha de
la derecha del carbono a la izquierda se
encuentra el bromo y así abajo se
encuentra el flúor y por supuesto el
hidrógeno se encuentra justo detrás del
carbono y ni siquiera podemos desde
encontrarlo verdad así que el bromo
tenía la mayor digamos la prioridad más
alta con el 1 el cloro con el 2 y el
flúor con el 3 verdad entonces si
nosotros vemos en qué dirección va
podemos ver que esto va en dirección
justamente de las manecillas del reloj y
si vamos en la dirección de las
manecillas del reloj usamos la letra r
que digamos se refiere al latín rectus
que también se refería a derecha verdad
así que este es el enantiómero r
y por eso ponemos la r aquí verdad este
es el ere bromo cloro flúor o metano muy
bien y ahora vamos a repetir justamente
todos estos pasos para el otro en anti o
menos muy bien entonces primero tenemos
que ir asignando la prioridad a los
grupos unidos a este carbono y
esencialmente son los mismos verdad aquí
tenemos el 1 aquí tenemos el 2 aquí
tenemos el 3 y aquí tenemos el 4 y ahora
hay que orientar los grupos de tal
suerte que el de menor prioridad
prioridad proyecte hacia atrás
nuevamente si el cloro es amarillo el
bromo es rojo y el flúor es verde y si
orientamos para que el hidrógeno apunte
completamente hacia atrás vemos que el
cloro está a la izquierda del bromo a la
derecha y el flúor hacia abajo ahora que
ya hemos hecho esto podemos continuar
con el paso 3 que es determinar si la
sucesión 1 2 3 va en dirección o en
contra de las manecillas del reloj y
podemos ver como más bien vimos en el
vídeo que esto se vería más o menos así
aquí está el bromo aquí está el cloro
del lado izquierdo y hacia abajo el
flúor verdad y el hidrógeno queda
completamente opacado por el carbono
entonces si vemos la prioridad que
teníamos marcada anteriormente podemos
ver que la sucesión 1 2 3 ahora va en
dirección contraria a las manecillas del
reloj verdad así que podemos ponerle una
letra s a este enantiómero enantiómero
perdón y eso es porque va en dirección
contraria a las manecillas del reloj y
la s se refiere al latín sinister que
significaba izquierda verdad así que
tenemos tenemos el r bromo cloro flúor o
metano y el s bromo cloro flúor o metano
y son distintas moléculas son
enantiómero el uno del otro